[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sois dans ton
cul [Musique] qu'est-ce que tu regardes
[Musique]
alors
ok alors euh euh M Lon ça et Robin
Williams je veux dire ça euh peut-être la
photo du Vietnam où gérer
les photos du Vietnam je veux dire toi  j'espère que
[Musique]
[Rires]
est une comédie musicale vietnamienne ouais,
musicale alors euh euh, comment as-
tu choisi comment en es-tu arrivé à lancer
Robin Williams était-il là au
début euh il était là avant moi ouais nous nous sommes
rencontrés dans les toilettes pour hommes
en fait nous  étions dans les toilettes des hommes et
nous avons dit tu sais whoa regarde la taille
de
ça, nous devons travailler ensemble d'une
manière ou d'une autre,
regarde la taille de ce microphone
woo gry
gry désolé alors il qu'il était ouais Wai pour
lui j'étais  je l'attends ouais devant
sa
maison s'il te plaît peux-tu lire ceci J'ai
ça dans un film appelé Rumble forkin non
je le
suis, euh nous l'avons développé un homme est venu me voir
avec une idée Adrien Cronau le vrai
Adrian il existe il vit il étudie le
droit et  Philadelphie c'est pour ça qu'une suite
va être vraiment difficile il est de retour il
est énervé il étudie le droit oh euh avec
il est venu avec l'idée qu'il avait un
colocataire qui était au Vietnam qui a inventé
l'expression Bonjour Vietnam qui
jouait du rock and roll était un peu drôle
et un peu ouais, je veux dire le vrai à
cronau J'ai vu le film et je suis allé, alors, elle
m'a fait ressembler à un vrai nom gu donc c'est
comme si Gandhi voyait le film se dérouler, je
n'ai jamais été aussi F,
je veux dire, si vous jouez Gandhi, c'était quelqu'un
qui buvait, sauvons
l'Inde  tu prends une petite licence
avec mais il allait bien, ce qui était bien,
je suis content que ça ne m'ait pas frappé, tu sais, euh, c'est comme ça que
ça s'est développé et nous sommes passés
par deux studios parce que c'était à l'
origine chez
[Music]
par ralentir  Je vais
[Musique]
parler, les gens qui fument de la marijuana
vont, euh, cela nous est venu en premier, nous avons écrit un
brouillon,
puis nous l'avons présenté à
[Musique]
Paramont et ensuite ils ont dit
non, c'est international,
oui, vous
voyez, j'ai un scénario que j'aimerais montrer.
[Musique]
toi, je dois demander à ces gens de
reculer. J'ai un scénario pour Disney appelé
Deep
Bambi où je joue là-bas,
tu sais, c'est en feu aussi. J'ai un
film appelé L'histoire du cœur de Gary
qui est tu sais ce que je disais,
euh bien  matin
VI
en ce moment il y a cinq traducteurs qui
y vont, l'armée n'est pas exactement l'
endroit le plus drôle au monde mais là
encore c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
des officiers du renseignement militaire pour traduire ce qui devrait être
dit donc si vous dites que pensez-vous de
tout le pays qui est juste foutu  Je ne
veux pas être ici, il est heureux d'être
n'importe où pour parler du
livre en question, oh, il y a cet enregistrement,
non, le livret qui mentionne comment
repérer le VC, oh, il y a un livre génial que
nous avons trouvé, c'est là que nous l'avons mis.  mettre
dans les émissions que nous avons tirées d'
un manuel de renseignement de l'armée qui expliquait
comment trouver l'ennemi et vous êtes
censé faire le tour et demander aux gens si
vous êtes l'
ennemi et s'ils disent oui, vous êtes
censé leur tirer dessus.  c'est pourquoi
j'ai mis le truc à propos de euh, j'ai
cherché Vi Kong et ils s'appellent tous
Charlie et je n'arrive pas à en trouver
parce que tous les Vietnamiens ont des noms
comme
non, ça semble très difficile de les localiser, n'est-ce pas
un problème de marijuana au Vietnam non, ce n'est
pas un problème, tout le monde
l'a, comment savoir si les gens
ont fumé de la marijuana, d'abord vous
traversez le camp dans un
camion de chocolat et s'ils mangent les pneus, vous les
arrêtez